بعد جدل الوصايا الذي اثاره مسلسل منى زكي
اثارت جريمه في محافظه الشرقيه جدلا حول
حق الام في الحضانه التلقائيه لابنائها
بعد الطلاق هذه الجريمه التي هزت الشارع
المصري بسبب تفاصيلها المروعه وهي لام
قتلت ابنها ذي الخمس اعوام طبعا قانونيون
طالبوا بان تكون الحضانه
واصلح لها من شتى النواحي واهمها الصحه
العقليه والنفسيه شددوا على ضروره ايضا
الخضوع لفحص نفسي لكن ما اثار هذه
النقاشات والمطالبات هو تكرار جرائم
ممثله سواء في مصر او حتى في دول اخرى
خلال السنوات الماضيه
مبدئيا كده كان حصل في اليومين اللي فاتوا
ظاهره فرديه من نوعها على هذا الاساس بدا
المجتمع يتكلم فيها طيب احنا دلوقتي
القانون المصري ينظم الاجراءات التقاضي
بالنسبه لمسائل احوال الشخصيه في قانون
رقم واحد لسنه 2000
دلوقتي الناس لما جت تتكلم اعترضت بسبب
الحادثه الاخيره اللي هي ظهرت وهي تعتبر
حاله فرديه بسبب الام اللي هي
ابنها قتلته في اكلت احشائه حضرتك مع
الموضوع ولا ضده ليه لا انا ضد ان الام
ازاي ان الام الحضانه
تسقط منها او ما تروحش اوتوماتيك لها لا
انا ضد التعديل اما مع القانون الحالي ان
سن الحدائق ليه لان الام هي الوحيده اللي
هتكون على الابن رحيمه
انسانه تقدر تعدل له تنظيمه ووقته غير
الاب خالص ولو هنرجع للشريعه الاسلاميه
سيدنا ابو بكر الصديق لما سوق اللي حصل
فرقه بين عمر وزوجته وساعتها قال له ريقها
خيرا لك من شهد العسل اريد ان استطلع رايي
استاذ محمد استاذ محمد انت مع تغيير او
اعاده النظر في هذا القانون وهل تستدعي
احداث فرديه تغيير القاعده نفسها هل يمكن
فقط يعني اعاده النظر او اضافه بند موضوع
الفحص الطبي النفسي بدون تغيير متن
القانون نفسه اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ساعدتك انا
عايز اعدل القانون واحد لسنه 2000 لان انا
ضد هذا القانون ان هذا القانون سلب الرجل
المصري كل حقوقه بما فيه سعادتك حق
الحضانه مش دائما مش دائما سعادتك انها
يعني مثلا عندنا في القانون الحالي ان
الحضانه في سن الام سعادتك لسن 15 سنه مش
في كل الاحوال بتكون الست كويسه والراجل
هو اللي سيء بمعنى ادق سعادتك كل ما في
الامر مثلا حاله حادثه زي اللي احنا طبعا
بصددها الان من قتل ابنها سعادتك ثم
سلقته ثم اكلته دي طبعا هو اكيد في خلل
استاذ محمد انت انت انت ليه مع التعديل
يعني
الاستاذه ايمان بتقول لك انه والله هذا
هذا شيء يعني القانون حدده
حتغيره ليه عشان حتى فرديه حضرتك انا مع
التعديل انا لا انا مع التعديل حضرتك لان
مش في كل الاحوال سعادتك ان الست بتكون
كويسه والراجل هو اللي السيء لا حضرتك
احيانا في امهات بترمي اولادها في الشوارع
وفي الملاجئ عشان تتزوج من اخر فكل ما في
الامر بيبقى الاب حريص سعادتك على ابناءه
اكتر من الام فمش في كل الاحوال سعادتك
بتكون الام هي سعادتك الاقرب او الاحن
لاطفالها